[Music]
the letter may be a capital but it has
just six thousand residents the island
state of Malta has a total population of
less than 450,000 people here spend lots
of time outdoors the streets of a letter
are generally bustling thanks to the
mild Mediterranean climate
locals are happy the city has been aimed
at 2018 European Capital of Culture well
it is a magical place you know have so
much history on this peninsula since the
sixteenth century so many people from
the Knights of Malta have come by and
they've left such a legacy which now I
think is finally being recognized on a
European level the letter lies on a
peninsula in the east of the main island
it was founded by the Knights of the
order of st. John in the 16th century to
defend against invaders they surrounded
the city with fortresses called bastions
in 1980 the entire city was listed as a
UNESCO World Cultural Heritage Site
every single house in the old town is a
listed building one of the main sites is
the Grand Master's Palace completed in
1575 one Grand Master Jean poppies sol
de la Villette gave the city its name
st. john's co-cathedral is the
convential Church of the order of st.
John visitors are not just dazzled by
the letters historical treasures the
city also offers some contemporary
highlights like the city gate and the
new Parliament building both of which
were designed by Italian architect Renzo
Piano the cultural capital of Europe
it's it's outstanding it's it's
fantastic for us as Maltese we are all
very proud this is the place to be this
is the place to be Valletta in 2018 more
than 400 different cultural events will
be held in Europe's smallest capital
throughout 2018 to mark this special
year
[Music]